αντάξε νομίζω ότι υχρειάζεται να ξέρι καθένα σας πούμε και ο άλλος που έρχεται κοντά
σου και θέλει βοήθεια νομίζωνα θελι να ξέρει α ξέρει όλος ο κόσμος ας πούμε
ακριβώς είπατε για την αγάπη του τασααδόπουλου για την καλία ίσως ήταν κι αυτό ένα
σημάδι ότι λίγο πριν πεθάνει περάσατι απότη γαλή ναιεγώ κάποιο ταξίδναιξεραείχαμε το τελευταίο μα σταξίδι
που κάναμε είχαμε πάει στην γίνα τους ολιπιακούς αγώνες ήταν μετά που είχε φύγει από
ότι προεδρία και μετά δεν ξεβω ιατί υπήρχε να πέρδεμα με τα ησυτήρια που ήτα
γυρίσουμε πίσω στην κύπο και παμε ας περάσουμε από το παρίσει καιεπίαμε στο παρίθευεβαι τ
ντελευταια φορά διότι δυστυχώς μετά καμια μόλις εγυρίσαμε αχάε πτευρίου αρχισε να είχε ενοχλήσεις με
την με την αγόστια το διοχικές οκτώ έδωσε τη μάχη του η νιώθεται ότι κάποιοι
τον ξέχασαν είσα σαγωγικά τωνσε σαοϊκά παντά των πούλησαν τότε είχε παράπονο από κάποιος όχι
ήταν πολύ νομίζω δε νομίτάξει σίγουρές τανοχωρέθηκε τ ότι είχε χάσει τις εκλογίας πολύ φυσικό
ήταν και ποσοπικά πιστεύω ότι ήταν κρήμαδι ότι ήταν και καλώς θαν ποεδώ στη δημοκρατίας
αλλά δεν νομίζωότι ένιοθεότι τον ότι τον πούλησα ήταν φιλοσοφούθε την την όλη κατάσταση ήταν
να πολιτευμένος σίγουρα αλλά κατούσε μια στάσει που δεν διπιστευώ ανιζούσε θαχθα είχατούσε μια πολύ
σως τη στάση λέγοντας τα καλά και τα κακά